AND FIRST, THE PROTESTS HONOR
ROLL.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WITH SOME CURIOSITY, I WATCHED
STUDENTS AND LEFT-WING
POLITICIANS TAKE PART IN A
NATIONAL WALK-OUT TO ADVOCATE
FOR GUN CONTROL TODAY.
>> WHAT PARKLAND SHOWED US IS
THIS COULD HAPPEN IN ANY ONE OF
OUR SCHOOLS.
AND WE AS STUDENTS CAN'T TAKE
THIS ANYMORE.
>> ONE MONTH AFTER THE HIGH
SCHOOL SHOOTING IN PARKLAND,
FLORIDA, KIDS AT MORE THAT 2,000
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE NATION STAGED
THESE WALK-OUTS.
DON'T BE FOOLED INTO THINKING
OUTPOURING OF YOUTHFUL RAGE.
THIS WAS A TOTALLY CHOREOGRAPHED
EVENT ORGANIZED BY A GROUP
CALLED "EMPOWER."
THE YOUTH WING OF THE WOMEN'S
MARCH.
THANK GOD THEY DIDN'T FORCE THEM
TO WEAR THE PINK KNIT CAPS.
LEFTISTS DO KNOW HOW TO ORGANIZE
AND PROTEST.
STUDENTS ORGANIZED BY THE
THOUSANDS.
WHO NEEDS HOMEWORK WHEN YOU CAN
GET CREDIT FOR SCREAMING.
OH, NATURALLY THEY WERE ENABLED
BY A FAMILIAR CAST OF
CHARACTERS.
>> PEOPLE ARE SICK AND TIRED OF
GUN VIOLENCE AND THE TIME IS NOW
FOR ALL OF US TOGETHER TO STAND
UP TO THE NRA.
>> WE'RE ALL MOVED BY YOUR
ELOQUENCE AND YOUR FEARLESS
INSISTENCE ON ACTION TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING YOUR
URGENCY TO THIS FIGHT, TO THE
DOOR STEP OF AMERICA.
>> Laura: OKAY.
LOOK, YOU HEARD LIKE TAKE YOUR
CHILD TO WORKDAY.
FOR THE ANTI-TRUMP, ANTI-SECOND
AMENDMENT CROWD, THIS WAS MAKE
YOUR STUDENT PROTEST DAY.
LIKE THERE'S NOTHING WORSE THAN
PEOPLE THAT USE THEIR KIDS TO
ADVANCE A POLITICAL AGENDA.
LIKE MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS AND
LOCAL POLITICIANS SUPPORTED THIS
WALK-OUT.
THE DEMONSTRATIONS WERE SUPPOSED
TO LAST 17 MINUTES TO HONOR EACH
OF THE PARKLAND VICTIMS.
BUT SOME OF THESE THINGS WENT ON
FOR HOURS AND SOMETIMES THEY
TOOK ON A FESTIVAL, KIND OF
PARTY ATMOSPHERE.
IN NEW YORK, STUDENTS MARCHED ON
THE, OF COURSE, TRUMP
INTERNATIONAL HOTEL AND AT THE
BROOKLYN BOROUGH HALL.
IN D.C., YOU SAW THE CLIP.
THEY GATHERED AT THE CAPITOL AND
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> WE WILL ACCEPT NOTHING LESS
THAN COMPREHENSIVE GUN CONTROL.
IF IT IS WHAT IT TAKES, WE WILL
SHAME OUR NATIONAL POLICY MAKERS
TO PROTECTING US.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A MORAL PROBLEM
IN THIS WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS IN OUR HANDS NOW AND IF
ANY ELECTED OFFICIAL GETS IN OUR
WAY, WE WILL VOTE THEM OUT AND
REPLACE THEM OURSELVES.
>> Laura: THAT'S NONPARTISAN
COMPLETELY.
THE MENTION OF TRUMP, JUST
IGNORE THAT.
GOODNESS.
SO MUCH FOR HONORING THE
VICTIMS.
THIS WAS NOTHING BUT A LEFT WING
ANTI-TRUMP DIATRIBE.
PEEL IT ALL BACK.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN WRITTEN BY
ANYONE AT MOVE-ON.ORG.
MANY EDUCRATS SUPPORTED THE
POLITICKING, A FEW
ADMINISTRATORS AND TEACHERS HAD
A BETTER IDEA LIKE THE ONES THAT
CALLED INTO MY RADIO SHOW THIS
MORNING.
>> AS A CONSERVATIVE SOCIAL
STUDIES TEACHER, I HAVE MIXED
EMOTIONS ABOUT THE WALK-OUT.
I DID MAKE TIME FOR THE PERIODS
FOR THE STUDENTS TO WAKE OUT AND
AIR THEIR OPINIONS.
WE HAD A GOOD DIALOGUE.
I WAS SURPRISED TO FIND OUT THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S MORE
THAN JUST GUN CONTROL.
IT'S MORE THE MENTAL HEALTH,
PARENTS NEEDING TO BE PRESENT IN
THEIR KIDS LIVES AND TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF BULLYING.
>> STRUGGLING PUBLIC SCHOOLS DID
HAVE WALKOUTS.
OUR PAROCHIAL SCHOOL TEACHERS
PUT TOGETHER A PROGRAM OF A
WALK-IN.
THEY WENT INTO THE CHURCHES AND
AUDITORIUMS AND RECOGNIZED THE
VICTIMS WITH PRAYER.
>> Laura: I REALLY LIKE THAT.
THINK ABOUT THAT COMMEMORATING
THE LOST, REMEMBERING THE
VICTIMS.
PRAYER OFFERED AS A CLASS.
TO ME THAT MAKES A LOT MORE
SENSE THAN YELLING INTO A
MICROPHONE IN FRONT OF SOFT
GOVERNMENT BUILDING.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT STUDENTS
HERE.
FOR ANYONE WHO TAKES THE TIME TO
LOOK AT OUR ACADEMIC STANDING IN
THE WORLD, STUDENTS NEED MORE
ACADEMICS, MORE CLASSROOM TIME.
NOT MORE HYSTERICS.
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST PUGH
SURVEY, AMERICAN 15-YEAR-OLDS
RANK 38 OUT OF 71 COUNTRIES IN
MATH AND 24th IN SCIENCE.
PLACES LIKE SINGAPORE, POLAND
AND MACAU BEAT US BY HUGE
MARGINS.
WE NEED SIT-INS LIKE SIT IN
CLASS AND LEARN.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
DEMOCRATS ARE USING THESE KIDS
TO WHIP UP ENTHUSIASM FOR THE
MID-TERMS, 2020 AND BEYOND AND
FOR VOTER REGISTRATION.
IT'S THEATER WITH REAL WORLD
CONSEQUENCES.
BECAUSE I'M TELLING YOU, WHEN